trying to piece together exactly who
might be behind this yeah it's I mean
it's not clear this is very early stages
but we're getting multiple social media
reports now coming in that this
individual spoke unaccented German that
he shouted abuse this is all reportedly
abuse against foreigners outsiders and
if we're and I've taken a look at the
full video taken from an amateur
somebody with a film with a phone
outside the mcdonalds the beginning of
the shooting spree we believe at the
location where six people were killed in
that video he has the body language of I
know this sounds weird but he doesn't he
moves in a way that doesn't indicate
that he's had any serious militant
military training and he is very light
skinned and as I say it's very early
stages in this but i think that the
important thing here is that people do
not rush to the conclusion that this is
automatically going to should be
ascribed to an act of islamic terror
this is the anniversary of anders
breivik murderous rampage when he killed
72 people in oslo and i think that there
is every possibility that this could be
an extremist act by right-wing
individual